with its incredible looking environments
in an ornate combat system horizon zero
dawn is an easy game to slip back into
the frozen wilds expansion makes a
return visit even more enticing with new
gear and challenges to seek out in the
frozen north with fresh enemies balanced
to fit into the game's latter half
there's also a new storyline which
slightly expands your knowledge of the
past and hints at events to come those
revelations alone aren't terribly
exciting but as an excuse to revisit one
of the best games of the year
this new journey hardly suffers from a
little disappointment Fresnel wilds
primarily takes place in a previously
unforeseen stretch of land that
encompasses roughly 10 to 15 hours of
new side quests and errands snow is a
new to horizon but it's never felt as
pervasive as it does here as you truck
up crunchy inclines pillowy sheets of
white break under foot while flurries of
powder puffs dance in the air and when
the Sun cuts through the atmosphere just
right individual snowflakes take on a
gorgeous pink hue that makes an already
pretty game even prettier this scenic
territory belongs to a tribe known as
the Bannock who have long lived in
isolation from the rest of society but
Nick tribes follow a strict code of
conduct that has more to do with
self-reliance and pride than it does
with justice and order that constraints
therein put pressure on Bannock in
various ways and most of your objectives
in the frozen wilds focuses on helping
individuals overcome their personal
struggles with tradition your primary
task has bigger implications however you
must seek of a Nuke shaman living on the
outskirts who unknowingly holds the key
to a new chunk of historical data and a
new facet of the technological powers
behind the scenes both this quest line
and personality-driven side quests
deliver heaps of dialogue which like
horizons exchanges at large range from
heartfelt discussions to perfunctory
filler but as excuses to clash with new
sparking mechanical beasts every mission
in the frozen wilds feels valuable
though the selection of fresh monsters
is somewhat small encompassing three
distinct additions they are hugely
formidable opponents that require a
considerable amount of effort to defeat
[Applause]
[Music]
there's also a new difficulty tear for
every enemy in the game one step above
corrupted which makes them faster and
stronger than ever and to top it off
there are bellowing towers that heal
nearby enemies almost faster than you
can damage them requiring an extra step
in some battles that ramps up the
tension from the gecko
of the few new additions the two grizzly
bear enemies one who uses ice and the
other fire stand out from the pack they
are capable of running on all fours or
standing tall on their hind legs and
employ a wide range of hard-hitting
attacks that punish delayed thinking in
a heartbeat
taking them down calls upon expert
targeting and intelligent use of
elements the latter of which is linked
to the new casting staffs introduced
with the pannier I adjusted the chilled
water flow rebalance here strapped on a
launcher and now she shoots freezing
spikes you weren't kidding these purely
elemental weapons are perfect for
exploiting enemy weaknesses to put them
into a vulnerable state to be followed
up by attacks from more traditional
weaponry he's proved useful beyond the
frozen north as well and it's easy to
imagine how their capabilities would
have come in handy during past trials
you'll also find a new grade of armor
that adds an additional modification
slot to standard armor types as well as
the binocs new gear which carries Auto
healing properties most new gear if not
given to you is acquired through the
usual mix of resources which now
includes the territory exclusive
currency blue gleam these are rewarded
for completing quests and exploring the
wilderness and are in very short supply
you have to work to earn your new toys
but that's okay the work is what makes
horizons so enjoyable the biggest and
farthest-reaching addition has to be the
new traveler skill tree geared towards
making your life easier and more
efficient traveler skills include things
like disassembling extra items procuring
resources while on horseback and
expanding your resource - at large all
things would have been immensely useful
throughout horizon seeing these new
skills having already finished the main
game isn't terribly inspiring unless
you've got a lot of lingering quests
left to hunt or if you've been holding
off on starting a new game plus that
said coming back to horizon for the
Frozen Wiles alone is still worthwhile
for the fights and sights but it
ultimately feels like a missing chapter
rather than an eye-opening extension of
what came before it's easy to imagine
how newcomers to horizon will benefit
from its new gear and skills the most
likewise its story feels better suited
as an interlude than the revelatory
companion to the conclusion it tries to
be if these are feelings that come up
after more than a dozen hours of
riveting battles and serene hikes flew
by so it's hard to get too upset at such
a captivating experience when it's all
said and done
[Music]
[Music]